みなさん、ここの高低アクセントで、私の友人
の敵のジョーイが最近、ある種
の日本語のQ＆A日本語フィードバックビデオ
を作成し、彼がYouTubeチャンネルに投稿しまし
た。そのビデオに
、誰かが尋ねたピッチについての質問があり、彼
はその質問に答えるときに私のチャンネルについて言及しました。
ですから、この
機会に、
日本語の高低アクセントを5分間簡単に紹介し
たいと思いました。何
人かの人がやってくるかもしれないと思ったので、これはスクリプトではありません
が、私は
日本語の高低アクセントを教えてきました。 約3
年前にたくさんの本
がありますので、すぐにお見せします。
これは
、高低アクセントのレッスンをするときにIIが使用する本の半分のよう
です。自慢しようとしているのではありません。
または
、私は自分の資格を見せようとしているだけですが、とにかく
ここに日本語の高低アクセントの5分間の紹介がある
ので
、高低アクセントとは、単語のアクセントがストレス
ではなく高低によって決定される
ことを意味します。 これはどういう意味ですか？英語
は強勢アクセント言語であり、これ
は単語
の強勢が特定のビットに対する強勢の種類の強勢によって決定される
ことを意味します。明日言うと
、その単語の一部はより大きな強
勢を持っています 周囲のビットよりも力が強い
ので、少し大きく、他のビットよりも少し長いです
が、ピッチは
少し高くなりますが、それほど高くはありませんが、
その音節に余分なストレスがかかる
ため、その単語のアクセントになり
ます。 日本語で「thickI」のような言葉があるとしたら、それは
最初の
アクセントに強勢があるということではなく
、そのアクセントに高いピッチがあるということ
です。
一部の言語には
英語となる強いビットと弱いビットがありますが、
日本語には高いビットと低いビットがあるため、強勢
アクセント言語とピッチアクセント
言語単語にアクセントがあり、 その
単語のアクセントはピッチの変化によって決定さ
れるので、ピッチアクセント言語の基本
的な紹介です。
次に、4つの異なる
日本のピッチアクセントパターンを簡単に紹介し
ます。最初のパターンは4つです。 最適な
コンプと
呼ばれ、実際にはモーラと呼ばれる最初の音節を意味しますが
、このレッスンの目的で
は、単語の最初の音節が高く
、残りのすべての音節が
低い音節と考えても問題ないと思います。 付着する粒子を含む
ので、例に戻ると、
sake high high low lowとすると、
粒子も付着し
ます。
この特定のパターンに問題はありません。
次のパターンはナカデカープ
パターンと呼ばれます。このパターンでは、ピッチ
は低く始まり、高く
なり、単語内で再び低くなります。
日本の例は、この例です。低音
が高くなり、再び
下がるホルトン私が家に帰り、粒子が
再び低音に付着します。
ピッチは
単語内で上下します。どちらも
ネイティブの英語を話す人は通常
、これら2つのパターンに問題はありません
が、残りの2つは少し注意が必要な場所
なので、
次のパターンは古いakkaと呼ばれます。
パターンとこのパターンでは、アクセント
は単語の終わりに落ちます。これは
、ピッチが低く始まり、単語
の最後の音節まで上がったままになることを
意味しますが、粒子は
低く付着するため、この例は
単語littleになります。 兄弟なので、
これはオットーと発音され
ます。ピッチの最初の上昇
は日本語ではそれほど劇的ではないので、おそらくあなたには比較的フラットに聞こえ
ます。それは本当に劇的なドロップなので、古い
古いバル lしかし、粒子
は低く付着するので、すべて高から低になります
toga toga togaネイティブの英語を話す人
は
、英語で通常起こることですが、日本語ではAlto
という単語のように、単語内にアクセントを入れようとする傾向があります
アルトのアクセントは単語の最後
にあるので、ほとんどのネイティブの英語話者
は、合計ではなく合計または
合計ではなく合計または合計では
なく合計と言います。ここでも覚えておくべきこと
は、ピッチが最後まで高いままであるということです。
単語のそれからそれ
はtogatogatoga togaを落とします完全に落ち着い
ていないそれは間違っていますそれはまったくtoga
全体ではないので、ピッチの低下
はつま先から次の
粒子になります粒子が付着しているように見えます
ゆっくりと立ち上がり
ますピッチは
バイナリシステムで示されるため、これはこれと同じ距離のように見えます
が、実際に
は複雑さを許しません。これについて
はもっと詳しく説明します。 私のシリーズではetailですが、低く開始すると
高くなり、単語の終わりまで高く
なり、その後少し落ちます。
これが3番目のピッチアクセント
パターンであり、このパターンでは最後の
パターンはheybongパターン
と呼ばれます。 助詞全体で高いままである
ため
、ピッチの低下がないことを意味します。したがって、
このアクセントパターンを持つ単語は
、ピッチの低下がないため、アクセントがありません。
したがって、この単語の例は
、米国の単語を言う場合
です。 日本語では、それはMIDI
コンプです。落ち着いて準備ができているので、低く始めて高くなり、
高くとどまります。その後、
粒子はおそらくカカのように高く付着し
ます。
英語を
話す人は、最初
にアクセントのあるサイクルのようなことを言う傾向があります
が、これはそのサイクルが間違っているので
、最後に粒子を置く
と、サイクルのサイクルのようになり、
再び付着した粒子は高くなります
高低アクセントがないので、きちんとしたサイトをサイクルして
、コーカスを取得しません
でした。これらはすべて、最終的な
正面パターンの例です。日本語のちょっとした結合は、
フラットを意味します。ピッチが再びわずかに上昇
するので、実際にはフラットではあり
ませんが、多くあります。
これまでに取り上げた他のすべてのパターンとは対照的に、高低アクセントの単語をフラットに近いと考える方がよい
ので、この
日本語の特定の単語パターンは
比較的フラットであり、
それが日本人教師が日本語をよく言う理由の1つ
です。 日本語を母国
語とする人はこれらの単語を完全に台無しにすることが多いのでフラットです
が
、先に話した他のすべてのパターンで
は高低アクセントがあり、したがって
高低アクセントがあります。簡潔にしたいので、このレッスンの要約は
日本語です。 アクセント
言語強低アクセントとは
対照的に
高低アクセントがあり、4つの高低アクセント
パターンがあります。
スティックアイオワのようにオートモロッコがあります。
香港には警官がいるホームワウがあり
、アメリカ
やクサンガやゴー警官のようにちょっとボンがあるので、これらは
4つの主要な高低アクセントパターン
です。
私のパトレオンシリーズでは、どのよう
な単語
が高低アクセントのどのカテゴリに分類されるのかが好きなので、基本的な
例の1つは、
「ちょっとボン」で終わる動詞の
ようなものです。
単語は
ヨブでもトブでもありませんが、
ルークに言われたように見えるので、投票で終わる動詞は
このカテゴリに分類される傾向があります。これ
は、このような本
で話されている多くの多くの規則の1つで
あり、私が教えています 私の
パトレオンシリーズにあるので、
日本語の高低アクセントについてもっと知りたい
場合は、それもまったく問題ないかどうかを確認することを検討
してください。チャンネルをチェックする新しい人がいる場合は
、立ち寄って
くれてありがとう。
叫びなさい、そして私はあなたたち全員
とすぐにまた話しますさようなら